hey everyone I'm Abbi sharp welcome to
another edition of fertility files in
today's video I'm gonna be going over
everything you need to know about
commonly used fertility supplements and
alleged fertility foods I'm also going
to be joined at the end of the video by
my friend and my fertility acupuncturist
naturopathic doctor dr. Laura von Hagen
so definitely stay tuned for that later
on now before we get into it my general
disclaimer that the information in this
video is for educational purposes only
and you should always speak to your
health care provider before starting any
kind of supplement regime especially if
you're undergoing fertility treatments
okay so as a fellow infertility warrior
I can attest to how easy it is to get
suckered into doing anything suggested
for trying to conceive even if it's
seemingly complete BS if the internet
tells us to try it a lot of us will
there are lots of mommy blogs out there
recommending what to eat what not to eat
supplements and the like but aside from
your daily prenatal vitamin are there
really any legitimate recommendations
for fertility foods and supplements to
take to increase your chances of getting
pregnant let's start by taking a look at
some of the research on fertility
supplements that may be recommended for
helping you get pregnant and stay
pregnant now I just want to make clear
that this is just a brief summary for
the video sake so we'll also leave a
link below to my blog for some more
details and the references as well so
number one folic acid studies have shown
that folic acid plays a significant role
in oside quality implantation fetal
growth and placentation in women we do
have research suggesting that it may
improve Oh sites with other research
confirming its role in embryo
development and growth in terms of male
fertility one research study found that
folic acid resulted in 16% decrease in
sperm damage while another study found
that improved sperm count and motility
number two zinc so research has found an
inverse relationship between male
fertility and zinc levels meaning male
infertility coincides
with lower zinc levels while higher zinc
levels tends to be linked with higher
sperm counts zinc supplementation has
also been linked with lower sperm damage
in men in women the research is less
reliable as it's mainly animal-based but
early animal research suggests that zinc
deficiency may be linked with improper
embryo development due to a defect in
placenta development as well as
decreased ovulation ultimately zinc
supplementation could possibly help with
infertility in women but more actual
human research is needed
number three is vitamin D so evidence
suggests that women with higher
concentrations of vitamin D tend to have
higher ovarian reserves and a site
quality vitamin D may also play a
protective role against endometriosis by
increasing endometrial thickness inside
the endometrium number four omega-3
fatty acids so research suggests that a
diet high in omega-3s can improve
reproductive success by improving OC
quality in women with one study seeing
improvements when two percent of total
calories in a woman's diet came from
Omega threes number five is vitamin E as
a powerful antioxidant vitamin E can
help reduce oxidative stress which in
turn can possibly reduce the risk of
common reproductive disorders such as
enemy tree OSIS infertility PCOS etc
vitamin E may also help increase
endometrial thickness by increasing the
blood flow to the endometrium in women
vitamin E supplementation has also been
linked to reduce sperm damage in men so
there may be benefits for both men and
women suffering with infertility number
six coenzyme q10 so research suggests
that coenzyme q10 supplementation may be
linked with improved ovarian response in
women with low ovarian reserves it may
also help with PCOS symptoms by
balancing insulin and sex hormones in
research done on male fertility coq10
has been linked with higher sperm
motility and count so again possible
benefits for male and female infertility
number seven in us at all in a research
study with over 900 women being treated
for an ovulation supplementation of
inositol improved pregnancy rates by six
point 1 3 percent
improving embryo quality and the number
of a sites retrieved as discussed in our
PCOS video which I'll link here we also
know that in AUSA tall is a powerful
adjunct for women with PCOS with
research suggesting that it may help
restore ovulation and improve your
chances of pregnancy number eight is
melatonin one 2014 review found that
melatonin acts as an antioxidant to
improve egg quality and may increase ivf
pregnancy rates by as much as twenty one
percent number nine is acai e berry
powder an ongoing study conducted by
ccrm fertility which is my fertility
clinic has shown promising results on
the effectiveness of acai berry powder
and pregnancy outcomes for women
undergoing IVF this effect is likely due
to its high antioxidant levels despite
the small sample size 81% of study
participants achieved ongoing clinical
pregnancies but of course more research
on this is definitely needed number ten
is l-citrulline evidence suggests that
l-citrulline may be associated with
increased sperm count and motility in
men however research on l-citrulline and
women is extremely scarce number eleven
is selenium so research on selenium and
female infertility is likewise very
scarce one study found that selenium
deficiencies were associated with
improper fetal development pregnancy
complications and miscarriages on the
other hand research has found that
selenium supplementation in men may
improve conception and sperm motility
number 12 is b12 how fitting so in
addition to folic acid which we already
discussed research has found that b12
supplementation in men may help improve
sperm count and motility number 13 is
n-acetylcysteine or NAC so when men with
a condition that involves the
enlargement of the veins in the scrotum
any C supplementation combined with
surgery improves sperm quality and
pregnancy rates but of course we don't
know if it was the supplement or the
surgery doing the trick in women with
PCOS research suggests that
supplementation of NAC may help induce
ovulation but of course more research
is always needed number 14 is pqq or a
really long word like pyro Lyle Quinn no
lien Queen own I don't know
now while research is very limited there
were a few my studies finding some
improvements in reproductive performance
however of course we do need some human
evidence before we can make a lot of
suggestions number 15 is iron so one
long-term study found that 438 women
with infertility decreased their risk of
ovulatory infertility when they
supplemented for iron for over an
eight-year period again more research
would be great number 16 is acetyl
l-carnitine or ALC there is an early
research that ALC may be linked with
improved Oh site quality and maturation
possibly by preventing oxidative stress
in the body because of its antioxidant
properties however we definitely need
more evidence to confirm this number 17
is l-arginine while quality research is
limited some pilot studies have
suggested that supplementation may help
improve ovarian response and a metrium
quality and associate pregnancy rates in
women it may also help improve sperm
motility and count in men number 18 is
maca although there is very little
quality research on this one 2016 review
found that maca powder was associated
with improved semen quality but most of
the studies were seriously flawed so we
do obviously need better quality ones to
make suggestions number 19 is bee pollen
and propolis now one animal study
conducted in 2011 found that the
consumption of bee pollen in male
subjects was linked with improved sperm
quality while women with endometriosis
saw a 40% increase in pregnancy after
consuming bee pollen again we need more
quality research in this area number 20
is royal jelly so animal research has
shown that royal jelly which is produced
by bees may help increase ovarian
hormones and promote hormonal balance
due to its alleged estrogenic effects
obviously you know what I'm gonna say
human trials are needed to confirm
now number 21 is bromelain while it has
been speculated in a lot of fertility
circles that bromelain in pineapples can
cause blood thinning to supply more
blood to the uterus thereby preparing it
for implantation and of course pregnancy
the research in this area is admittedly
very scarce so it may or may not help to
eat a lot of pineapple when you're
trying to conceive or you'll just end up
with like a lot of mouths hoarse I don't
know I like pineapple so you do you
number 22 is choline so I didn't suggest
that human fetuses receive a large
amount of choline during pregnancy hence
why the needs of a mother-to-be are very
high around 450 to 550 milligrams a day
although research linking choline with
fertility is limited we do know that
women's intake during pregnancy is not
actually always adequate so there is
some suggestion by experts that
supplementing may help again obviously
we need more research on whether or not
this affects conception at all now I
think it's safe to say that the bottom
line for almost everything here is that
we need more research we just do people
need to do more research on women's
health some of these supplements have
more supporting research than others and
are therefore more likely to be used in
fertility clinics across the world but
unless you have an actual clinically
diagnosed deficiency it's unlikely that
any one of these alone are necessarily
going to make or break your chances of
getting pregnant whether or not you want
to incorporate these into your fertility
regime is totally up to you and should
be between you and your health care
provider next I want to talk about the
foods and dietary patterns that may help
support conception and a healthy
pregnancy number one plant-based protein
good news for my plant-based followers
and fans research has shown
that's swapping out animal protein for
plant-based protein may help decrease
one's risk of ovulatory and fertility
while another study found that consuming
more animal protein resulted in a 32%
increase in the risk of infertility
possibly because of the higher levels of
saturated fat antibiotics and hormonal
residues in contrast research has shown
that specifically non heme iron which is
the type of iron that we find in
plant-based proteins may help decrease
the risk of an ovule Ettore infertility
this doesn't mean that you need to go
completely plant-based or vegan
necessarily but as always I do think we
can all benefit from incorporating more
plant-based protein into our week now
number two is full fat dairy
research has uncovered an association
between consuming higher amounts of low
fat dairy and an ovule Ettore
infertility while seeing an inverse
relationship between high fat dairy and
risk of anovulatory infertility all the
more reason to go with a really
delicious creamy 5% yogurt number 3 is
nuts like walnuts so research suggests
that consuming 75 grams of walnuts per
day may be associated with increased
sperm motility count and morphology in
men possibly because of the
alpha-linolenic assets in the nuts
as well as nutrients like selenium B
vitamins and zinc number 4 is eating
breakfast so research on women with PCOS
found that eating a larger breakfast
compared to their lunch or dinner meals
was associated with an increased chance
of ovulation compared to women who ate
larger meals later on in the day the
larger breakfast also helped reduce
insulin and testosterone levels which is
totally key for PCOS management number 5
fiber rich carbs while the research on
fiber and fertility is admittedly mixed
one said he found that increased intake
of cereal fiber or 10 grams of fiber per
day was associated with a 44 percent
decrease in the risk of an ovule Ettore
infertility in women over the age of 32
however this decreased
was not seen unfortunately in younger
women it was also found that a low
glycemic index diet for patients with
PCOS resulted in higher percentages of
ovulatory cycles compared to patients
with a normal glycemic index diet okay
so now you know some potentially healthy
foods to include what about foods to
potentially limit when you're trying to
conceive number one trans fats one said
he found that even a 2% increase in the
consumption of trans fats was associated
with a 94 percent increase in the risk
of ovulatory infertility so it may be
best to reduce consumption of processed
foods or anything with hydrogenated oils
in the ingredients list number two is
high glycemic index carbs while the
research is definitely limited in this
area one study on 438 women found a
positive correlation between intakes of
high glycemic index carbohydrates think
like white bread or white pasta or sugar
and sweets and the risk of ovulatory
infertility meanwhile consumption of low
glycemic index carbs happen to reduce
this risk in fact for women with PCOS
once that he found that a lower glycemic
index diet improved menstrual regularity
in 80% of the women studied number three
is caffeine now consuming caffeine has
been talked about quite a lot in
pregnancy circles and in the fertility
community one large study researching
the connection between caffeine
consumption and conception found that
women who consumed over 500 milligrams a
day took over nine months longer to
conceive than women who consumed less
than 500 milligrams a day another study
found that increasing caffeine intake by
just a hundred milligrams a day was
associated with increased risk of
miscarriage a third study found that
women who consumed over 75 milligrams
all the way upwards to 900 milligrams a
day how to increase risk of spontaneous
miscarriage compared to women who
consumed less than 75 milligrams a day
so more research is definitely needed to
understand these findings in the context
of conception but for now the guidelines
in pregnancy at least is to have no more
than two
milligrams of caffeine per day which is
about equivalent to one 16-ounce coffee
on average number four is alcohol so
research has found that low to moderate
consumption of alcohol which is about
one standard drink a day for women does
not necessarily negatively impact the
chances of conception
however consumption of 10 or more drinks
per week does seem to have a negative
impact the thinking is that alcohol is
pro-inflammatory which can possibly
increase the inflammation in relation to
the endometrium which in turn may
influence fertility so now that we've
gone over food I want to conclude with
some other general lifestyle
considerations when trying to conceive I
may be a dietician but arguably these
suggestions are probably the most
valuable and evidence-based so they
really should probably be your first
line of defense before you go to
expensive supplements or drastic changes
to your diet that is of course in
addition to whatever your doctor is
suggesting medically number one exercise
now research has found that any type of
physical activity may be associated with
an increase in fertility among obese
women while moderate physical activity
may result in a small increase in
overall fertility regardless of BMI
obviously BMI is not a great indicator
of health but I'm just using this
because that is what the research is
based on now having said that I want to
note that strenuous exercise can result
in hypothalamic dysfunction which in
turn can lead to menstrual cycle
irregularities and hormonal suppression
which of course then can cause an
ovulation moderation is definitely key
when it comes to exercise so choose an
activity that you enjoy doing and listen
to your body in terms of intensity
number two stress management
multiple studies suggest that
infertility is significantly associated
with stress as it may contribute to
irregular menstrual cycles and
ultimately an ovulation if stress is a
really big fact
in fertility learning how to manage your
stress may play a really big role in
your personal fertility journey some
possible ways to manage stress include
exercising attending therapy or finding
a distracting hobby to take your mind
off of the stress personally I actually
found that acupuncture strangely was
very stress relieving for me so that is
another option for you I know that is
totally easier said than done especially
when trying to conceive but find some
strategies that work for you and stick
to them number three is getting enough
sleep so sleep deprivation in women may
impact the release of luteinizing
hormone aka LH which is what triggers
ovulation and regulates your cycle this
may explain why one analysis found that
female shift workers were at higher risk
of miscarriage and other menstrual cycle
disturbances again we definitely need
more research in this unique area but we
know how important sleep is for hormone
regulation and stress management in
general so this really would make total
sense so that my friends is what the
research says but I also want to get
some clinical real-world insight before
we sign off here so I have with me my
friend dr. Laura von Hagen who is a
natural Pathak doctor here in Toronto
where I live who specializes uniquely in
fertility and she actually was the
person who did all of my fertility
acupuncture as well okay thank you so
much for joining me Laura so first of
all I'd love to hear a bit about you
know what are some of the most common
fertility diagnoses that you see
patients in your clinic for mm-hmm so
the most common thing that I see is
polycystic ovarian syndrome and this as
you know is characterized by irregular
periods and infertility and something
that I was actually diagnosed with at
age 25 so a lot of people reach out for
that the next most common thing I would
say is a combination of low ovarian
reserve and poor a quality
so typically these are people who have
maybe seen a fertility specialist and
they've been told that their AMH is low
which is how we measure ovarian reserve
or maybe they've done IVF and
unfortunately they had a failed cycle
due to poor egg quality so at that point
they're coming in to see me looking for
some intubated care to kind of try and
boost their egg quality or their sperm
quality if that's the issue for their
next cycle yeah amazing for sure makes
so much sense to me and and just from my
own experience and see how many women
come to me and ask for you know
recommendations when it comes to PCOS so
that totally makes sense to me now one
of the big criticisms of the supplement
world is that they're expensive and
there's not always a lot of great
evidence to support them in some cases
all of which we've kind of gone through
in this video today so I'm wondering in
your clinical experience is there one or
two supplements that you find makes the
biggest difference in outcomes for
people who might be on more of a budget
mmm-hmm absolutely and you know this is
something I hear often but it's actually
reason I love doing integrative
fertility care because we have quite a
bit of robust evidence for using these
supplements to help support outcomes
specifically an idea um so if I had to
pick two which is hard it would be Co Q
10 and vitamin D um Co Q 10 is an
antioxidant and been shown to improve
egg and sperm quality and when it come
to Co Q 10 it is something where the
forum really does matter it needs to be
in a fat soluble base in order for it to
be absorbed so it is something that
would spend a little bit higher price
point on just to make sure that you're
actually then absorbing it into your
body the other one is vitamin D and it's
incredibly important for fertility and
those Canadians and now that we're like
quarantine inside look we're just not
getting enough vitamin D and adequate
vitamin D has been shown to improve
pregnancy rates it can reduce your risk
of miscarriage and what I find most
interesting I can actually raise your
AMH so your ovarian
Reserve and the thing with vitamin D is
you really have to test you can't guess
dosing I've seen this across hundreds of
patients I give the same dose I get a
very different level so if people are
really low I will recommend by maybe
injection but with your fertility
specialist they are the ones who should
be really testing your vitamin D and
then that will help us guide our dosing
for you and it's not something you would
just ask your doctor can I get a vitamin
D test I know it does cost money correct
at least here mm-hmm
it's not covered by OHIP um so I run it
as a naturopathic doctor I can run blood
work or they can do with their doctor so
like it doesn't matter either way it's
not covered some fertility clinics off
the get-go they run it on everyone other
ones don't and it's one of those things
in my initial consult and especially
with PCOS so there's robust research
there is vitamin D I'm always asking
when do you have your vitamin D tested
and I want to see adequate levels
because I've seen cycles that didn't
work out and when we run vitamin D they
were super deficient and once we got
leveled up we did see success and I
can't say it absolutely that's the
reason why but I'm sure it made a really
important part well
amazing now obviously like we've said
like supplements are highly
individualized based on the population
based on blood work based on needs but
for the general population who are
trying to conceive are there any you
know any of these supplements that you
think would be valuable for all of us to
be paying attention to mm-hmm and a
great question Adi and I think that we
need to put a little bit more focus on
two things specifically the first one
being melatonin and then the second one
being l-carnitine so for the first one
melatonin is actually an antioxidant and
it can help improve our a quality and
also help with implantation in the
uterus interestingly there's actually
receptors for melatonin in ur uterus and
with so much stress and so much exposure
to blue light in front of our computers
all day doing more zoom meetings we're
just not getting enough and generally
people love taking melatonin it makes
them sleep really well other than some
you rivets are vivid dreams and it's a
pretty cost-effective supplement so I
think more and more we're going to see
it being used and used with IVF cycles
and then the other one is l-carnitine
so we used to get a lot of hype for
weight loss but the research doesn't
really support that but as an amino acid
it is important for energy metabolism
and the reason I like it is because
we've studied it with a drug called
electro salt or Kamara which is super
common for PCOS to help with ovulation
and when we add in the L carnitine we
see that ovulation rates go up we see
that their endometrial uterine lining
gets thicker and most importantly we see
clinical pregnancy rates are higher and
so it seems to help with that energy
metabolism and it actually acts more
like a shuttle to get Co Q 10 into our
cells so it's best taken with the Co Q
10 so we can see more and more research
coming out on that and because we're
often giving it needs from me I'm giving
supplements while patients are taking
medications I really like when I see B
shirts that they're being used together
so I know that stay for me to prescribe
to my patients really interesting so
when it comes to supplements obviously
the supplement world is quite
overwhelming are there any guidelines
that you try to stick to when it comes
to choosing supplements to make sure
that you're getting a quality brand
let's say ad like you go to the grocery
store and you can buy a go and you can
buy generic ibuprofen and you know
you're buying the same thing and that's
not the case for supplements in general
Canada has much stricter guidelines in
the US my preference onions to work with
Canadian companies and I don't work with
one specific company I don't have any
you know ties or financial because I
want to keep that separate and we'll use
a variety of different companies but
what I'm looking for is that they've
done third-party testing for things like
their fish oils that I can see that it's
standardized to the active ingredient so
especially for herbes it's not just the
amount but what is the active ingredient
and then the other thing is is the
amount per capsule or per dose actually
wetson study because what I see a lot of
times is these products that have
one two ten things with laundry list
where they sprinkle coated in thing but
people might have read about it on the
internet but it's not like a fifth of
the dose that they've actually
researched and so that's where I can
kind of come in and knowing all the
research put together a better plan and
the therapeutic dose and so I wish there
was more guidelines around this but I
tried to really stick to Canadian brands
that I know and trust and I built up
that relationship with them okay and
then finally for those who have already
complicated relationships with food
which isn't mentally a lot of my viewers
people who watch my my channel and also
just women in general are there any non
diet recommendations that you think you
can make that also will have a
significant impact on fertility outcomes
because we know that I had the
significant impact on fertility but they
also don't want to stress patients out
about it but we never till 'ti it's
already so stressful and I had patients
come to me where they've seen other
health professionals who put them on
like a organic gluten-free dairy-free
Paleo diet and it was just like way too
much I'm way overwhelming and so I try
to make it a piece but not stress about
it too much in terms of non diet
something that I use a lot of is
acupuncture and I think that it can be
really really important unfortunately
I'm not doing it right now because we're
only doing principal consultations but
for helping with straps for helping with
blood flow for helping with relaxation I
think it can really help and then the
other one is movement I think that
movement is really important and we know
that exercise can be really great for
fertility and overall health and again
not something that I want to stress
people out about because we actually
don't want to be over exercising when
we're trying to conceive because then
that can kind of swing the pendulum too
far and at high times I've had to cut
back patients and tell them that they
can't go to CrossFit you know seven
times a week that's not allowed and so I
really just ask patients well what do
you like to do is it walking is it
swimming yet I don't really care because
the exercise that you like is the one
you're gonna stick with and that's
what's going to be the most important
just getting a little bit more movement
in your day can be really really great
for mental and physical health yeah
that's totally and I'm totally on board
with that message I really I think that
all of these suggestions are great but
if it stresses you out more then we're
more harm than it and it than it does
good so I think that's a really good
kind of take-home message here but thank
you so much Laura for joining me I will
leave some links below so that people
who are seeking out some some fertility
support can can find you as well yeah so
be happy to connect I'm pretty active on
social media as well and I look forward
to absolutely thanks Laura I I think
it's safe to say that women and men who
are struggling with infertility are
often just so desperate to do whatever
they can to improve their chances while
the research in this area is often very
limited and it's unlikely that in most
cases adding a little bee pollen will
make or break the chances of getting
pregnant but I will say that a lot of
these recommended foods and supplements
are generally low risk and generally
healthy for you so again it's important
to remember even if you do not make any
or all of these dietary changes you are
not at fault for your infertility lots
of people get pregnant despite doing the
exact opposite of these suggestions but
I will say as somebody who has struggled
with infertility I understand that
sometimes you just want to feel like you
did everything possible in your power
that you could and sometimes making
these small changes to your lifestyle
may give you some sense of control even
if there's not a whole lot of research
to back them up ultimately if it brings
you a peace of mind
it may be worth exploring some of these
options but if it makes you more anxious
and stressed to think about all of these
different little things it definitely
will not help the cause
either way it's always best to speak
with your unique health care provider
the best supplements and best dietary
changes for you baby dust to all of you
and on that note I hope you enjoyed this
video if you did be sure to give it the
thumbs up leave me a comment below if
you have any more fertility questions
that I can answer in this series
subscribe to the channel and I'll see
you next time on Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]